i don't know i don't know put the flour
in the pan
ice bag chill it
chill it yeah
hey guys it's katie and we're back in
the studio to give jasmine another
translation recipe
challenge i've taken a recipe put it
through google translate and used
lots of different languages for example
we've gone from english to hindi to
armenian to hawaiian to russian
japanese and many many more and then
back to english to give us this
hilariously altered recipe we heard from
you guys that a lot of other awesome
youtubers do something like this like
brandon ferris melinda and many many
more
we were inspired but what jimmy fallon
does with music lyrics on his show
if you like this go check all of them
out they're super fun and i think it's
time to give this recipe to jasmine i
got some new surprises for her i think
she's gonna be a little scared
but i'm excited let's go i don't know
what you have
up your sleeve you're gonna it's gonna
be really yummy
okay ear drum
wow i don't want to give you too much
information but it is
not a dessert some surprises for you
surprises
we are going to have a lot more
ingredients out than what is needed for
the recipe
and a lot more cooking utensils
you increased the difficulty you were
too good last time we need to up the
challenge
people commented they thought we should
make a little harder for you okay thanks
guys thanks a lot guys all right well
let's do this let's make eardrum
[Laughter]
drumroll please
step one add 16 milliliters of flour and
salt to the plate
make half a hole right now i'm thinking
we're making pasta
half a hole is probably a well in the
middle okay
16 milliliters i'm just gonna do
16 ounce
my gut tells me that there's somehow
math involved and that didn't bode well
for me last time i don't know i put that
as step one
so 1.5 i needed 2 oh times 4. 1.5 times
four wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
all right so i'm gonna use the food
scale five ounces
twelve oh right it's a pound now we are
going to make half a hole which i assume
is a little well add two whole seeds to
the hole
[Laughter]
sunflower seeds and sesame seeds two
just two
two tablespoons maybe two two
two eggs an egg is just some sort of
scene
in theory if you think hard enough how
is it egg in a seed
it's how it starts
yeah exactly you can fertilize it i
think it's two whole eggs i'm so scared
i like that you committed though that
you're like doing it
we gotta make eardrum step three nine
add the any any eggs this is a lot
harder than last time you're doing great
add
9 egg yolks all right so i'm going to
separate the
egg whites and the yolks and i'm going
to add 9 yolks to the well
you seem more scared this time you threw
a surprise at me in the morning
i'm running on so little sleep finally
number nine
okay step four bake the dough by rolling
spreading folding until soft soft
it's like a poem by yonder
baked the dough by rolling spreading
folding until soft soft
is that your shakespeare impression yeah
do you like it that was really good
great thank you combine dough by
kneading until soft
okay i'll add this first first i'm gonna
mix it in like this
it's not in the directions though i am
just gonna combine this like i see
in videos then i'll knead it until it's
double soft so what are you doing right
now i am trying to
incorporate all the ingredients together
this is not soft maybe two negatives
make a
positive maybe soft soft actually means
hard
i'm pouring it onto the table it's well
combined enough now i just need to
knead it until it's like one dough baby
feels very dry is it feeling soft off no
hard hard my dough kind of looks like an
ear it does
what step five put the flour in the pan
ice bag it's like a wrap put the flour
in the pan
ice bag it's an ice bath
i'm gonna put some ice in the bag and
then
put it on top of the flower put it in
the bag
i don't know i don't know chill it
chill it yeah chill it
step number six in a large bowl the beef
pepper onion parsley dish vegetable
salad dressing
oh okay it must be barbecue sauce
ranch is more of a vegetable salad
dressing
do you know what you're making right now
no
[Laughter]
tea are we braising this with tea
is this asian because i've made tea
braised meat
and salt we went from like advanced to
extremely advanced
pepper onion parsley
all of it i guess vegetable salad
dressing
i mean it has to be the barbecue i would
say yeah i mean
there's other stuff but my heart says
one to three tablespoons
[Applause]
okay one you know what we'll start with
one and we'll see
tea and salt do i really have to put
tea rhymes with cheese kelly has a hint
for you
what is tea technically it was part of
the blank
trade spice trade i would say it's
garlic or cheese
i'm gonna do garlic i'm gonna mix it i'm
gonna look at the consistency afterwards
i think one tablespoon of
barbecue sauce might be not enough does
this look familiar to you at all like
have you done anything like this before
maybe we're making beef meatballs with
pasta
this seems a little dry i think i'll add
a little bit more barbecue sauce
[Laughter]
do it yeah go for it no i'm not doing
anymore i'm not gonna do anymore
step number seven make a piece of meat
and turn it into a piece of paper
combine
the meat and flatten silence means i'm
right
no laughing step 8 boil for 400 minutes
in a 400 degree oven you are nice
thank you this recipe is so kind
boil for 400 minutes i don't want to eat
this
in a 400 degree oven oh broil for four
minutes that's not broil is not 400.
bake for 400.
can i request the next recipe to have no
math i'm sorry
400 divided by 60. sometimes numbers
just get added onto a number it's
not math really maybe there's an extra
zero in there
let's bake it for 40 minutes in a 400
degree oven
i'm nice so i got to flatten this are we
doing like a pasta and beef layer sort
of situation
i want to make meatballs but a piece of
paper just tells me i gotta flatten it
so a ball is not flat all right you know
i'm gonna commit to meatballs
if it's wrong it's wrong but i'm still a
winner because i get to eat meatballs
i'm just gonna grease my pan
doing this challenge what does it feel
like it feels like i'm in an escape room
and sometimes you run out of hints and
so you're just kind of sitting there
looking around waiting to fail sometimes
it feels like that
all right i'm gonna bake these in the
oven at 400 for
40 minutes brb the oven's at 400 i'm
gonna put it in for 40 minutes
which i'm now realizing is way too long
so i'm gonna put it in for
20 minutes if it needs more time we can
check on it
all right there's more to do let's go
back
step nine place the two coach in a large
saucepan over medium heat cut into
two pieces and occasionally soften until
brown with caramel
the only thing that's really calling out
to me are brown with caramel
i'm thinking browning or caramelizing
some onions
i'm using a lot of butter i'm going to
put the onions in the butter
and just kind of cook it on low heat
until it caramelizes for this many
onions i feel like it'll take about 45
minutes the onions are done caramelizing
it probably looks
burnt on camera but it's not it's
deliciously beautiful and
nice and caramelized let's move on to
the next step step 10
put the ricotta cheese noodle leaves
beans
parmesan egg salt and saffron in a
medium sized bowl
more beautiful and special they sound
like
texts from my grandparents
okay so ricotta all of it noodle leaves
all right i think i'm gonna go with
basil i feel like the flavor palette
strongly aligns with this
beans beans i have chosen to add the
black beans
this is probably my least confident step
that i'm taking
as i was rinsing it i didn't feel as
confident so now i'm going to half ass
this step and not add the full can maybe
just like a little bit maybe half
it doesn't ruin the flavor palette it's
just uh i haven't seen it before
parmesan egg salt
and saffron is that too little
a little bit more okay i think that's
enough right now i really do think that
the beans were the wrong
move i think the flavor combo will be
fine seems cheesy basily
nothing wrong with that i'm gonna
combine it until it's
more beautiful and special i feel like
i'm talking to someone i feel like
someone's teaching me
you know it's not very robotic like put
in the oven
mix until well combined it's you are
kind
and you're beautiful and special so
eardrum is a really positive recipe
yes we love positive energy step 11
in a large bowl cook regatto in salted
water less than the recommended meal
time
finish with jumbo pasta paste repeat
that hurts cook regatta
rigato rigatoni so
cook it al dente i suppose finish with
jumbo pasta paste
oh jumbo shells great great great so i
have
rigato and jumbo pasta paste
i brought some water to a boil and i'm
just gonna cook these
until they're al dente and then once
this is done i'll do the same thing with
the
jumbo pasta paste and i did salt the
water so don't come for me
okay next step add the cooked rigoto
beef sauce
put it aside we go to beef sauce add the
beef sauce
to the cooked ragota it went from
regatta to rigota
ricotta just because it said beef
i'm going to use this beef stew
is it italian it's made in ohio is this
it
do you like the surprises we added no i
do not like these new surprises katie
it's so hard
this is like an escape room with a zero
percent pass rate i'm going with the
beef stew
i don't think that's right you gotta
commit now
i can't do control z so i'm just gonna
add marinara on top because i think this
is the right answer
if anything it's just more flavorful
this is so much
harder than last time step 13 fill
the large muscle with the diamond
vegetable mixture
so stuff this a lot i don't know how
much i've actually never stuffed pasta
before
but i'm just gonna make it until it's
nice and full i finished stuffing the
pasta shells or the jumbo pasta paste
i'm gonna go get the meatballs out of
the oven and we will move on to the next
step all right i have
brought back everything that i've made
so far katie tells me we are
in assembly mode next step break a large
dutch oven with
10 inches of olive oil 10 inches
first i'm gonna do one inch this isn't
even enough for 10 inches
10 inches wide just greasing the dutch
oven
i forgot that we had the dough so now
i'm kind of thinking we're gonna spread
it thin and lay around which means we
would have to just
grease the sides next step place the
dough three centimeters wide like
a double like a frying pan next step
says
fold the rolled dough into triangles and
raise the pot
so i'm gonna roll it out and flatten it
and
line it against the edges of the dutch
oven
do you feel like you're on the right
track because i think we're out there
yeah the fact that i even found a
rolling pin
i think it tells me something i feel
happier now yeah you see him
i was so stressed earlier one day i'm
gonna get back at you it's gonna be so
hard
it's not even gonna be in english that
doesn't seem fair
well too bad life's not fair the dough
got so
dark please don't fall next step remove
the extension
and press it to the side so i'm gonna
make sure it's
well lined in the pot i assume it needs
to be pretty right this is where i fell
short last time in strawberry kinking i
wasn't looking ahead into
how the outside would look step 18
price 375 degrees fahrenheit all right
i'm gonna go pay for this
375 degrees fahrenheit be right back are
you gonna
bake it i think price means bake
price money what do you do with an oven
before
preheat the oven to 375. ovens preheated
next step place pasta dish wrapped in
rigatoni
mozzarella boiled meatballs
fried eggs provolone stuffed clams
caramelized onion sausage this dish is
like
doing the most like you could not do
more
than this coated rigatoni mozzarella
boiled meatballs fried eggs why are
there boiled eggs
i'm gonna do fried eggs because that's
what i want to eat so if it's wrong
i'm just gonna blame it on my personal
preference provolone
stuffed clams stuffed jumbo pasta paste
with diamond filling and caramelized
onion sausage
both onion sausage mixed together is
assembly and
important if i'm gonna slice it and it's
all the same flavors
i am gonna put some rigatoni on the
bottom
of this dutch oven here on top of the
dough
i don't think i need everything
mozzarella i'm just gonna line it
let's just hope that's right i feel like
assembly is the funnest part
cute eardrum is so cute okay meatballs
just everywhere i suppose it looks bomb
you know what kind of
uh person would like this joey tribiani
from friends
this is like a dish for him fried eggs
the yolks are runny so i must be very
delicate
looks like breakfast it does breakfast
of champions
who would you serve this dish too
honestly i feel like kids would really
like this it'd be fun to make
and then when you eat it's like wow it's
like a pie
but it's savory it's pasta
stuffed clams all right how am i
supposed to put these in though
this way i wonder if it's supposed to be
face down
yeah these black beans i
i do it but i think it'll be good it's
extra protein beans are healthy dutch
oven black beans give you dutch oven
caramelized onion sausage
is it like together do i like
okay definitely the onions it's going in
there because that was 45 minutes of my
life
in everyone's life yeah in person
everything smells so
delicious together it's like all the
scents are married
all right yeah so back to this
i don't think it needs to have that many
sausages
i'll line it so everyone at least has a
bite of sausage
ooh it's not bad huh geometry
geometry three sausages in a dutch oven
okay cover the dough with the sausage
and cover cover the dough
with the sausage cover the sausage with
the dough maybe it got switched around
in the translation
it's not big enough to close i'm going
to seal it
next step 45 minutes there were 30
minutes with
it heffiastian what's that mean
45 minute oh bake
covered for 45 minutes and then 30
minutes uncovered
yeah how
how did you get that really
i am shocked and then hephaem i think is
how you say it i'm not sure but that
it doesn't matter i got it i just want
to tell you it derives from the
pre-greek word
of unknown origin being crippled god of
fire metal working
stone masonry you thought that would
have been a good hint
so obviously what is this topic
i would have not connected that mines
are gonna come from kelly
from now on i'm sorry
i thought it was cool well the next step
is
good for 300 minutes so
huh oh cool cool for
30 minutes cool for 30 minutes i'm gonna
put in the oven
45 minutes covered and then after that
uncovered for 30.
i feel so good it's done i think
almost at least it looks interesting
i can't say i'm proud yet but it's here
it's cooled
okay next step before cutting cool the
cutting board in the refrigerator
i think it's fine okay last step serve
with orange oil
i assume orange oil is our
red sauce okay i'm gonna flip it
like last time one two three
oh my goodness
ear drum you're beautiful how do you
feel
looks like i made a little ottoman am i
crazy has tasty done a video on this
yeah is it a tampana
tampani timpano was it called timpano
timpano and rea did the video on it it's
from the movie big night
it's based off an italian dish called
timbalo doesn't it look like a drum
yeah it does let's get in the real guy
so we can compare it
i hope i did okay okay ready yeah
yeah there you go oh i did a good job
you did a great job it's the moment of
truth where i figure out
what went wrong oh so thick
what's an appropriate slice size pretty
big
oh interesting i thought i would be able
to see the layers a little better
but you know what at the end of the day
there is pasta and there's meat in there
so i would say i'm a happy camper i want
to see what's in here
i want to know where i went wrong
[Music]
what though mine looks nothing like this
yours isn't bad let's give them a try
okay i will start with this one the
original so i know what it's supposed to
taste like
it seems kind of dry oh cheers
it tastes like lasagna don't love the
egg yolk the graininess of the yolk kind
of interferes with the texture
here at play let's try mine with the
black beans
and barbecue sauce why did i do that
[Music]
the black beans are totally lost the
barbecue sauce in the meatball
actually gives it a sweetness and a
tanginess that is quite nice i will
admit
well that was very fun definitely more
challenging than the last time
if you guys want to see us do this again
make sure to dm katie for some
suggestions because i'm not allowed to
know
what dish we're making but yeah thanks
for joining us see you next time
bye
you